the only reason why I drew all that
because you I'm really really good at
this is to talk about inequality so
let's just write an example one
okay so have a look you can tell me
already that the difference between an
expression and an equation was an equal
sign so what's the difference in an
equation and an inequality say via okay
it's not an equal sign in you will it's
an inequality sign so think we read this
as x1 3 take away X on 5 is greater than
or equal to 2 yes
okay I never don't just do it for me to
share just raise your hand if you think
you could solve it just okay all right
hands down now we're going to solve this
one and I want to point out something
better than usual as we do it
can someone give me a suggestion for the
first line what might I do okay don't
come back this at you the phrase I heard
was purple and black what does what's
cost multiplying about like why do we
cross multiply in a situation like say
this don't understand a situation like
that what is the function of cross
multiplying what what is it about the
next line which by the way it is why is
this second line superior to the first
yeah yeah because oh looks like you guys
are like me you don't like fractions
either so the first thing we do is get
rid of them okay so cross mods plays
very useful strategy for doing them okay
however back up
you do you notice a difference between
what you've got here
and what you have over there so here
these things are not actually like
opposite sides of equation these guys
are sitting together on this left-hand
side right it doesn't actually make
sense to cross multiply because you get
something different over here which
won't be the same over there okay so now
I'm now I'm actually getting something
more useful I want to get rid of
fractions still but I want to do
something consistently across the whole
thing so instead of saying cross
multiply which is what I'm doing here
right over here I'm going to multiply
both sides by 15 every single term by 15
so tell me what should I write 5x take
away 3 X all right so shouts got us from
line 1 to a line to someone to take over
from line to line 3 well this is an easy
one come on even if you're not awake yet
you could probably have to go they saw
somebody hasn't said anything yeah what
are you reckon boy tell me what to do
five days yeah okay now just before we
do that in the ask you for the answer in
a second remember we have word you have
language to describe everything that
we're doing right as much as possible be
specific with your language
don't say do stuff to the things over
the head right what is it what's the
name the thing we're actually going to
do it so the answer it is 2x and what do
we call this what have you done to the
left-hand side I think you have terms
that are alike
do you agree when you've got terms and
they're the same kind of term and you
put them together what is that called
against that's what I see you're
collecting like terms thank you okay
right away okay I haven't done anything
to the right-hand side
final line what you're told
although you just get away with that but
particularly inequalities finding it's
greater than or equal to
okay I need happy with this solution do
you think it's true how would you know
whether it's true or not yeah
so I got breath what do you think how
could we actually know whether we've
gotten this right what do we do to the
left-hand side okay so if I just back up
a little bit to say this guy right or
this guy the way you can donate them to
180 or three Saturday you're crazy or
the way you can know 32 is 33 is the
solution is you pop it back into the
first load okay and you will find 33
divided by three is eleven you take away
seven tonight works okay now over here a
little bit a bit trickier because um
what number are you going to test well
yeah because this is actually not what
value is it this is an infinite number
about your sign from 15 going to 16 17
actually I've missed the whole infinity
of solutions already could be between 15
and 16 there's an infinite number of
numbers now it's just in any of those
were okay all right but I think we're
all right I think these lives there okay
now just note this right
all the ways you went through you
basically did this didn't you like these
were the exact principles that you use
you treated this thing more or less like
an equation which is kind of weird to me
because if I said to you he's away and
he's another word
what's the relationship between those
two words they are opposites drank if
you wanted Vince he would call it in
Toulouse right they meet the opposite
Dave so when you're saying someone was
really inefficient versus wow that was
really inefficient you might have a
compliment you know or you're insulting
them and they mean the opposite thing
that's what that's perfect means right
have you noticed what was just strange
in what you just did you took an object
that was the opposite of what we were
talking about five minutes ago and you
treated it as exactly the same thing and
you'll agree with the solution does that
not strike you as strange
in fact yes a because we told you to do
so okay now here's where I wanted sort
of making up this event okay
yes we're gonna stretch you this because
actually despite how different these
things uh-huh most of these principles
are the same but I'm trying to point out
the difference because they're not all
the same
okay so I need a bit more space
underneath this I want you to think of
this think of all the things you can do
to an equation right what things have we
already seen on the board that you can
do to both sides of the equation
okay you multiply by numbers what else
can you do
you can can add you can subtract right
well if I gave you an equation like this
what operations going to get you out of
that you would sway right what about an
equation like this what would you do to
that you would take the reciprocal of
both sides wouldn't you okay
now I'm pulling these out on purpose
because for inequalities
even though they look so very much like
equations there are some really big
problems with how you deal with these if
you treat them as exactly the same or it
is if a is greater than B okay and this
one's going to be important for you not
equality
okay Asprey stock standard thing to do
would be to multiply both sides by a
chosen number okay so if you chose a
positive number like we chose three
before is that still true and B or any
number such that a is bigger than B is
that still true I think it is it still
works right so for example three bigger
than 2 9 is bigger than 6 so far so good
okay what about this
if I multiply both sides by negative one
is it still true so if I said when I
said 3 is bigger than 2 that means
mine's bigger than its so going from
line 1 to line 3 if I had negative 3 and
negative 2 which way is the inequality
sign going
it's it's flipped around hasn't it right
it's going to be opposite direction and
the reason why is because these things
are actually completely different to
these things even though so many things
can be the same they're actually
fundamentally different objects thanks
so multiplication by negative what else
do you notice on the board might go a
bit awry if you have the same operation
on both sides and the direction of
inequality I think 3 2 bigger than 2 so
what about 1/3 and 1/2 is 1/3 of bigger
than a hug it's mine is a it's also
switched around so if you take
reciprocals it's the same deal now the
reason why I'm making such a big deal
about this is because students all have
trouble with this right you treat them
just like equations and forget crucially
they're completely different it's not
just like a funny rule like um when you
multiply my name is just mr. turn the
thing around okay it's not a rule it's a
different kind of object right so you
treat it differently it does different
types of things if you're ever unsure
come back to numbers which is actually
we're going to do later this week we're
gonna stop looking at a drop I'm gonna
think about numbers of how they work
that way you remember which
it's not going